so cities across the country are seeing
a major spike in violent crime now a
scary scene earlier this week in new
york city so to shoot out
in the middle of the street during broad
daylight thankfully
no one blessedly was hurt while cities
are pushing to defund the police
nationwide slate has a new piece out
that suggests
cops should be forced to keep their guns
in smart
lock boxes whatever that is and need
permission
to take them out all right dan i'm going
to come to you first since your former
law enforcement
if you read this slate
car stalled available an intersection or
a cat stuck in a tree so this is why
they don't need
uh armed weapons with them except for
some of the time also if you could tell
us what a smart lock box is that would
be great
i don't know what that means well this
this article
should be written more about how we
don't need the media not how the police
don't need firearms
because of all the dumb ideas i think
i've ever heard
from the liberal media defund the police
and have
police carry their firearms in smart
lock boxes where you use your
fingerprints
to open it is probably the yeah that's
probably the dumbest and
i mean think about it you just kind of
set it in the opening without knowing
they said that the author said oh don't
worry it's just a traffic stop who'd
need a gun
really how do you know that because i
can show you probably 50 or 100 videos
in under five minutes pulled off any
video platform
of police officers who thought they were
pulling someone over for a traffic tip
ticket and ended up in a coffin yeah so
i think the
writer from slate maybe dial it back a
little bit and start doing some
journalism homework
before you you know keep insisting
police do things that will get them
killed
greg i'm coming to you next because
you've heard a lot of dumb ideas
in your lifetime dan says this ranks as
maybe the dumbest he's ever heard where
does it rank for you
it's pretty stupid but it's coming from
slate so he's dumb as a rock
ladies and gentlemen we are legitimately
you see what you did there
yeah wasn't that clever and it's friday
and i'm not even drunk yet
we are legitimately in the 1970s when i
was looking at that video the crime is
rivaling
death wish in its randomness by the way
the asian hate crime in new york
is overwhelmingly done by non-white
mentally ill homeless people
has nothing to do with wuhan but we got
gas prices that are going through the
roof we got jimmy carter part two we got
crime
all i want is a threes company reboot
and some mr pibb
and i'll be right at home there was this
old line that we used to hear that a
conservative
is a liberal mugged by reality now
today's liberal
is doing the mugging and i'm not talking
about good traditional liberals i'm
talking about these young
defunded police types that have no idea
the the science of incentives and
disincentives
the past two years have been a lesson in
disincentives and incentives
if you make it impossible for cops to do
their jobs then they can't
that emboldens criminals if you release
criminals before the cops are done with
their paperwork
that emboldens criminals if you only
focus on law-abiding gun owners
not the illegal handguns that are being
used you embolden criminals
all of these ideas are coming from
places like slate
and from academia so if we listen to
them this will only get worse
the long-term consequences of all this
will be a withdrawal of public law
enforcement
the rise in private security that can
only be afforded by the wealthy
the cities will get worse people will
leave america will become much more
spread out perhaps
safer but that's what's going to happen
and the people that are going to hurt be
hurt
are the older people still stuck in the
cities because they can't afford to
leave
they're the ones that will be victims
like the elderly asians that you see
every week it's not a mistake that
they're older because they can't get
out jessica there does seem
to be some early inklings of buyer's
remorse among
some of the democratic city council
members in cities that have defunded the
police this year i'm talking
new york this week minneapolis some of
them saying
maybe we need to get some of the funding
moved back into the police department
what
i mean these are your people give us the
breakdown uh
well some of those people are not really
my people they're democrats yes we are
we are all democrats and but i've been
pretty consistent about this since day
one when i heard the chant of defund the
police that it was a terrible terrible
terrible idea and the people who were to
be hurt most by that
were people of color in communities that
actually have the highest level of
approval
for law enforcement and police and
that's only contin greg i'm glad that
we're
we're friends again now though i have
something to say about the wuhan thing
uh you'll be wrong but it's okay no i'll
be right
on the police front i mean whip clyburn
i don't know when the man doesn't get it
right but he certainly did after the 20
20 20 20 right midterms when he said
that
the chant of to fund the police cost
democrat seats abigail spanberger talked
about that as well and it's really
interesting to see here in new york city
what's going on with the mayoral race
because eric adams
who is black and is a former police
officer has now taken the lead in some
polls
one poll he's behind catherine garcia
but he's surpassed andrew yang
talking about being tough on crime but
also supporting law enforcement and i'm
sure it'll be a cornerstone of val
deming's campaign against marco rubio
for senate in florida she was the first
black female police chief in orlando
that's where we need to be we need to be
tough on crime
we need to be for smart reforms that
everybody agrees we need to make
hopefully we can get something done with
tim scott
who seems ready to deal there but to
fund the police it was a non-starter and
only 18 percent of americans are
supportive of it
jagen i obviously saved the best for
last so the floor is yours
oh golly
[Laughter]
you betcha hot stuff
you know how bad it is for the democrats
that you have somebody
like james carville now he is passed his
cell by dave but he's still smart
writing in the wall street journal
saying that
it is the democrats who are tough
on crime they are the party of law and
order he wrote this this week
pres donald trump's stunning display of
lawlessness set an example for criminals
to crawl out of the shadows and believe
that there would nev they would never be
brought to justice
he's literally blaming a crime wave acro
when donald trump called the rioters
rioters
who sent in federal authorities into
portland to at least protect
federal buildings when not one democrat
until the poll numbers turned against
him would say hey
violence and the burning of cities and
the looting of businesses
is a bad thing this is the desperation
is the worst cologne and i can smell
james carville from here
he's throwing anything he can against
the wall trying to change the narrative
the fact is it is not just the defunding
of police
it is the bail reform you hit an elderly
asian woman in the face
you get put out on with no bail there
are
there are weak mayors they're weak
governors uh
releasing cop killers parole boards are
filled with liberals and then they're
weak district attorneys who would rather
rather like coddle and swaddle
criminals that stan then stand up for
victims of violent crime
that's the party of law and order all
right we gotta leave it there
um but stick with us because coming up
next we're gonna talk about how
americans are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else